There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most-hyped products
to test for ourselves.
I'm a big fan of the Made
by Mitchell Blurshes.
I tried a purple blush from them before,
and I loved it, and they just came out
with a lavender shade, so I had to try it.
Applying it on top of
my makeup was a mistake,
because it's a pastel.
It was basically like
I applied a white blush
over my bronzer.
Plus, it actually made
my foundation patchy,
which is an issue that I've
never had with this formula.
I think I might've just overblended.
Trying it out on bare
skin wasn't any better.
It just leaves this
very gray-looking cast.
I looked like the Corpse Bride.
I think I'm better off using this
as an eyeliner and eye-shadow base.
Clinique has finally come
out with a lip-gloss version
of its iconic Black Honey lipstick.
This color is definitely identical
to the lipstick version, just glossy.
Here's what they look like side by side.
I liked it a little more
once I dabbed some off.
This color is just really flattering.
I have to say, though, this gloss formula
is not my favorite.
I think they were going
for a cushiony feel,
but it's just kind of sticky and thick.
Looks great, but it doesn't feel so great.
ELF released this Halo Glow Liquid Filter,
and the world stopped.
Could this actually be a dupe
for the Charlotte Tilbury
Flawless Filter? Let's see.
On this side of my face I
applied Flawless Filter.
It's gorgeous. It's glowy. It's perfect.
Now, on this side, I
applied the ELF Halo Glow.
Look at them side by side.
They are almost identical.
I would say that the ELF one
has a hint more coverage,
but it still gives that same
your-skin-but-better effect.
And the Charlotte Tilbury
one is slightly more glowy.
Slightly.
I say save yourself the extra 30 bucks
and get the ELF one.
Side note: Look at the
size of this doe foot.
It's huge!
You guys know I adore Rare Beauty.
I was so excited when they dropped
these Kind Words matte
lipsticks and lip liners.
I had to get the color Gifted,
because Selena said that
that was her favorite.
The lip liner is supersmooth.
Even though it's matte,
it doesn't drag or pull on the lips.
Plus, it's a twist-up, which I love.
The lipstick is so creamy and pigmented.
You could probably put
this on in one swipe.
It's definitely one of
the most comfortable
matte lipsticks I've ever tried.
Scrandie Beauty is a
brand I found on TikTok.
I kept seeing videos of its
Spicy Sauce lip plumper,
and I really wanted to test it out,
since I haven't had much
luck with lip plumpers.
I applied it to half my lips,
so we could see if it
actually does anything.
So, you apply it slightly
above your lip line,
and it starts to feel a little spicy,
then it starts to feel tingly and spicy,
and then at the three-minute mark,
you also start to feel
a warming sensation.
I love lip plumpers,
so I don't mind the roller
coaster this takes you on.
It feels kind of good to me.
I definitely notice plumping,
especially with my top lip.
I really like this lip plumper,
and I also like that it's clear,
so you can wear it on top of anything.